I remember at one point you're telling
me in slack you're like these people
just offered me 2 million bucks for this
yeah I'm like holy [__] you did it we
started the podcast my first million you
just made your first two million
congrats like I can't believe this
worked out you're like I'm not going to
sell though and I was like wow this
guy's insane and I was like that's an
insane
[Music]
story all right so I can't tell how many
times I hear this people will DM me
every single day and they'll say hey I'm
just calling my shot right
now today I'm I'm a small boy in three
years from now I'm gonna be on MFM I'm
gonna be on my first million I'm gonna
make my first million do an XYZ yeah
every single day I get a message like
that here's somebody who actually did it
this is isan he was my intern turn guy
who's made millions and millions of
dollars lost millions of dollars and had
a crazy journey in between you were the
guy who I created this podcast with yeah
you were the guy who the the cover of
our podcast he created it um the intro
song originally the original intro song
he created it you know I didn't even
know how to record audio at the time
this guy did all of it um you went from
behind the scenes to now you're on the
stage here in my house and we're going
to record this episode so I've made it
you've made it that's that's the teaser
all right let's tell the
story all right what's up yeah what's up
what's up I uh so people don't know this
so you are isan you uh I've met I've
known you since you were 18 years old
you still are kind of like 18 years old
I yeah yeah yeah I still look like I'm
18 years old yeah you're 23 now yeah all
right so I'm thinking this episode is
kind of
like your title wasn't intern but it's
gonna be good for YouTube so we're GNA
be like intern my intern became a
millionaire yeah I wasn't glorified and
like my official title is cheap as stuff
which is like kind of like in and by the
way I got a good track record with this
I don't know if I'm doing anything but
I'm good at picking people because I
worked with you at age 18 yeah Steve
Bartlett 19 maybe 20 uh years old
there's a guy another guy named is Sean
who just tweeted out today that he's
like those four months I worked with you
were super influential he went from like
guy just working someplace now he's got
an eight fig agency so that was cool
yeah uh Danny Miranda works with me for
a little bit people know him in the
podcast game now he was with us for a
couple months before he started creating
contest so I I feel like those two Sean
so maybe getting getting people that
like sound similar to your name yeah
yeah the closer the better actually um
all right so you've had a crazy run but
Let's do let's do the history so how did
we meet uh well I followed you on
Twitter when I was like 12 13 years old
I was tweeting my whole strategy was let
me get my like like profile picture
before do that I'm reintro the the one
part which is yeah one thing that people
don't know is this pod was started
actually not with me and Sam me and you
yeah I hit you up on uh Twitter DMS yes
yeah and I saw that you were doing a you
were a podcast editor for somebody else
I knew um I think Corey or
angelist yeah Cory Levy and so I I had
this idea all right I want to do a
podcast I hit you up I didn't know how
old you were but I was like hey do you
you want to produce for me then we got
on a call I was like oh man this is like
a kid sumwhere you were at school at the
time and I was like will you do you know
how how audio works and you're like yes
I got you so the if people see the the
cover art of the podcast yeah you made
that um the initial like you know 20
episodes or whatever all those intros
and all the audio you made that yeah
then we started doing business
experiments together this was at a time
where I was kind of like I think I want
to build an audience yeah and I also
want to just launch some businesses we
launched Ecom businesses we launched a
bunch of [__] together and then we went
off our own ways and then you had a
crazy Journey after that where you made
millions of dollars lost millions of
dollars and all the rest so we're going
to talk about all that let's start at
the beginning so I dm'd you but we you
were actually were on Twitter when you
said we were what 13 years old 13 years
old I followed you I was trying to just
get my face like on all these people
because I I'm from Australia right
there's no there's no Silicon Valley
there's no like VCS and cool angels and
all these people so I was like let me
this is my Avenue to get to these people
um and let me just like even if it
wasn't like a lot of value ad I'll let
me just tweet random [__] at you guys
and I was doing that so if you just go
on my Twitter you'll find tweets of me
you know tweeting off to Shan random
[__] and you respond here and there but
yeah so that was like when I was yeah
literally like 13 14 whatever and then
couple of years later when I was s the
podcast with Cory is when yeah you DMD
me and I was like yeah I already know
who you are and let's do this I think
your name was I think I found you
because your name was also Sean and I
was like this is like this is this is it
to
be I can't find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hopspot grow
better talk about the start so when we
were working together tell me some of
the things you remember because I
remember I only everyone's got their own
version of History yeah I remember in my
head like you know what we were thinking
back then but I'm curious and this is
our first time catching up in person cuz
you live in Australia um and you're just
in town so I to live it where I lived I
was living in Brisbane you also like way
back when lived in Brisbane yeah um so
what's your version of History what do
you remember the first thing I remember
well I think the first thing I remember
is when we're were doing the podcast
like cover out and stuff I sent you over
some like uh you know like here's
version a version B blah blah blah and
then you like hold on a second you
should add your name to the to the cover
yeah I thought I thought that was really
cool that that gave like me a lot of
confidence like okay yeah this I'm like
I'm you know a part of this is as well I
remember that was that was a cool thing
he did cuz I think maybe that's some
learning there people that higher yeah
make him feel special yeah yeah you make
it feels special um do that that was
that was like a really cool thing I
remember um also just like the kind of
craziness of like let's start a crystal
store today and then like a few weeks
later let's start this other DC thing
like make up make the store 72 hours go
off and and do it it was like it was it
was like some variation of like an
incubator but it's just
at this time I'm working at twitch I'm
earning out my deal we sold the twitch
I'm now earning out and I know okay in a
year I get this vesting check yeah but
in the meantime like frankly I was
pretty bored inside of a big company I
you know it's not I knew that's not my
long-term and I was like you know on the
side here what can I do to entertain
myself the podcast was one cool thing
I'd always wanted to do and then the
other would be like I would meet
somebody and I'm like oh this person's
killing it at Ecom yeah yo isan we're
making an store and I remember for the
crystals thing I was like I read some
article I saw some magazine like I
always trying to look outside of like I
don't look at Tech crunch to get Tech
ideas or like business ideas I look I se
I remember reading like a People
magazine and it was like Adele was
saying she won't go on stage unless she
has her like rose quartz crystal and I
was like what like that's insane like
you who believes in this crap and I
Googled it and I was like after Kim
Kardashian got mugged she had like a $4
million ring she got mugged and it was
like how did you recover she's like well
my crystals really grounded me and I was
like and then you see all these
celebrities I'm like if again I just
think people are sort of like I have
this tweet that's like uh the economy is
just smart people paying beautiful
people to Market to to to the sort of
like average people and I was like if
all the celebrities are doing this then
there's got to be a bunch of other
people that believe in this and so I
remember calling you and you're like the
best part about you is your game that's
my favorite thing is like if you hire
somebody with no experience there a
bunch of bad things like I'd be like
dude like I haven't heard from you in
two days where'd you go yeah but then on
the good side it'd be like he doesn't
know any better so I could just be like
hey we're doing this and it's going to
be we're going to launch it in two days
and you're probably just like I don't
know is that normal maybe that's normal
right like yeah CU besides this like I
never I've always been working for like
internet people I've never had like a
traditional go to an office and right
and like I was I remember the time I was
like like uh I'm like I'm going to
finish uni should I go and be a
consultant for like some Bank whatever
yeah you ask me so cuz yeah I just
didn't know what the other I guess I was
just scared cuz I didn't know what the
other world was like I was like all
right this is kind of right normal and
doing this so um so crazy stuff like
just yeah creating different Ecom stores
or different experiments we did like a
newsletter the good terrible bad very
bad that was like that one top five Ro
right milk Ro yeah milk Road became a
successful newsletter company but I
guess before that I didn't even remember
that we we did launch a newsletter
called the the no good very bad terrible
something something something newsletter
I don't know what why we called it that
but we basically were launching a bunch
of experiments and I remember at the
time one one of my takeaways from that
is that Crystal Store for
example I didn't even know what winning
looked like so one problem with an
experiment it's easy to use this word
experiment but the way a science
experiment works a hypothesis you're
like I believe this then you run the
test and it either confirms it or it
doesn't yeah but I was using the word
experiment wrong which was like I'm just
going to try a bunch of [__] without
actually knowing like what is the win
condition yeah what is the success or
failure condition of this and so like
now that I look now that I actually have
an e-commerce like our e-commerce
business now you know is is doing very
well it's a figure e-commerce business
now that I know what an Ecom business
looks like I can go back and think about
our our Crystal Store actually was doing
very well like I just didn't know so for
example we were running Facebook ads and
the key metric for all e-commerce
businesses is your row ad your return on
ad Spin and I think we were getting like
1.7 yeah well like the Rocks we were
selling these rocks for like 50
60 they're crystals yeah Crystal and
yeah no I remember like like the first
few hours we got that that Shopify
dinging like that was I mean most people
start up a store and they don't have
sales for like a couple of days or
whatever or weeks and so yeah it I think
Al problem was like just didn't continue
we didn't continue exactly cuz now that
I look back it was like 1.7 to 2X and I
remember thinking oh it's supposed to be
3 or 4X I think CU I had heard some
idiot saying that somewhere and I just
thought that's what it is and so I was
like I guess this is bad turn it like
shut it down let's do the next thing uh
you know in retrospect I you know maybe
I'm glad I'm not running a crystal store
but at the same time like there is a
lesson there of I mean sticking to it is
obviously a c like you can't win without
the stick to itness but one of the
things that makes you stick to it is not
just willpower it's like knowing your wi
condition so like you do you even know
what to look at and do you know what
winning looks like do you know what the
Benchmark should be so that you can
actually assess a successful versus
unsuccessful experiment that's one of my
learning one of my things I remember
from back then the other one I remember
is like with the
Pod I we kind of like we called our shot
a little bit like we made this Google
doc yeah of the plan the one page plan
and now I call that my kickoff doc but
it was like before we started it I wrote
this out do you remember that that doc
yeah I remember and it was well the
first thing that you hopped on was like
you need your a thousand true fans like
that was the very very first thing you
go like if we just got this you can
build a pretty big business just with
with a th000 people that was like the
first thing I remember and then you had
a few things like we need to get to
100,000 listeners and had a bunch of
other other like maybe build a business
of or like you know these ancillary
businesses adjacent businesses across it
and I mean you did all that I was like
that's one thing you kind of step back
and it's like I'll share the dog I'll
put the dog uh if you're on YouTube I'm
G to put it on the screen so you can see
literally like word for word what we
wrote back then and it's not that it it
all happened but it definitely didn't
happen on the timeline I remember
thinking we're going to hit let's get to
100,000 downloads per episode so that's
the thing like per episode I want
100,000 downloads by the end of the year
so it's like 12 months yeah took me
three years so like you know now we do
that but like you know it took three
years for us to ever hit that Mark
so it's kind of this old phrase like
don't confuse a clear view for a short
distance it's like I feel like we had a
clear view I just thought things would
happen faster I overestimated kind of
like what could be done in one year but
with that one because it's so fun I just
kept going and like sure enough like you
know it all we we we that was like the
right thing that keep going those other
things shiny things and that was like
the right one the one that was making no
money actually costing me money because
one of the things I wrote in that Doc is
I plan to lose $10,000 a year doing this
yeah but it'll worth it because I
thought you know creates like some
Serendipity yeah and you kind of talked
about that too like content creating
Serendipity or like just being online
and being like in the mix yeah Fortune
liking a post or replying to something
or putting putting yourself out there
who cares if someone that's like when
you I mean it's different for you though
if you post there's millions of people
going look at it but like just for like
a regular person when you post like a
tweet and it says like 116 Impressions
it's going know like that's still like
that's still some people that have
looked at it and you don't know who it
is but you know later down the line that
could that could come inead when we talk
about uh some of the stuff I'm doing now
I can I've gotten all my opportunities
every single one of them has been like
through Twitter or like through some
like LinkedIn or some email or thing
I've sent and late years later down the
track it's all come tell the story about
the billionaire so what what happened
there that started on Twitter yeah uh
that was a that was me just like saying
I need to I just made this like kickass
investment and let me like I want more
people to know about it so I I was like
talking to like journalist and stuff
like that like hey write about the story
and no one was really uh taking the time
but there was one dude that was actually
yeah on Twitter he um I just he wasn't
responding to anything else I went on
Twitter I saw he active there I was just
like I just kept liking his post I
didn't actually say anything and then
like he checked out my LinkedIn profile
and we started talking he's like okay
yeah let me write about the story and it
was like it wasn't like a Forbes or
anything it was like a pretty small
newssite that it's it's so weird that
they posted that article and a few days
later a billionaire read that article
and then
we'll tell that story a sec so even that
is like um there's this phrase that I
read once I think Mark suster did a blog
post about this called lines not dots
basically the idea is like a line is
just a collection of dots like right
mathematically that's what a line is
it's multiple dots just all all
connected and so what he says is like
you know in he's like what people think
happens is they see on tv that you go in
you meet this investor cold you blow
their socks off with this pitch and then
they write you this just check and say
you know here you go son go go on and
it's like that's not what happens like
that's movies that's Shark Tank that's
not real and the real thing is dots and
so he's like you know many interactions
that stack up that when you look back
later is a line um and he's like
investors invest in lines not dots
meaning they're not just going to like
it's not the very first interaction
typically where it's all just going to
happen for you so it's following the
person liking the post replying to
something they notice that this person
said something smart not the first time
but the third time and then after that
they follow you back and then because of
that they see this other blun post you
wrote you don't even realize that one of
your 98 views was this person who's
actually legit and then go you know like
and then so those dots Stack Up and
ultimately that's how trust gets built
that's how this the framework this is
the the framewor
king watch me cuss baby this is what I
do uh yeah so that's I think you know
what you've done really well so all
right so let's get to the part where we
break up so at some point we break up we
work together for a while like I don't
know year I think it was actually a
couple years of like knowing each other
and like doing stuff enough yeah so we
get to some point where um you're like
you come to me one day you're like I
want a day trade or
something like to be fair you were
actually kind of good at this I remember
one time we were on a call and uh I was
like telling you like some instructions
or some like some action items and then
like there's like no
feedback and I was like yo are you
listening like what are you doing what
happened where is this thing on and you
were like oh hang on um Bitcoin just
crashed to
$3,500 I'm like this [__] is
looking at the Bitcoin price while we're
supposed to be working on our very
important Crystal Store or whatever we
were doing whatever you know scheme we
were in at the time yeah and I remember
being like like two reactions one like
annoyed like dude this guy's like not
paying attention two wait Bitcoin
crashed like sh you know he's buying
should I buy you're like because you
told me you're like Bitcoin crash I'm
trying to I'm trying to place an order
real quick it was down like 60% on just
that day everyone everyone in crypto
like knows that day it was very like it
was like in March or something it was
yeah yeah yeah it was and like it was
like you just never see it happen this
is like this is not some altcoin this is
like the coin this is this is Bitcoin
and so when that happened I was like I
I've seen a few of these and I just
wasn't a part of it and so I was like
sorry I know I should be working and
listening right now I was like I need to
act right now and so yeah I mean I
grabbed all the money I had it was a
couple of thousand and I well I didn't
just buy Bitcoin I was like the the
generate in me I was like okay let me
try and maximize opportunity so I went
on people know bitb I went leverage long
on bitcoin so I took all my money did
that and when I went leverage long means
what here in this case so so if you buy
$1,000 with a Bitcoin and you buy you
know 20x leverage that means you
actually buy $220,000 worth but if it if
it goes down by even a little bit yeah
you're you're going you'll have you'll
experience I thing called
liquidation so getting liquidated um is
like your worst nightmare and I remember
you were like like what four five grand
your full Grand that was my collateral I
was 20x or 25x leverage and when I
clicked the button to buy like
everything went Frozen and I was like I
was thinking oh [__] is it just me or
like I'm I'm kind of freaking out and I
go on Twitter that's when I was I I was
like not really talking I went on
Twitter and everyone else is like bitmax
just froze and I'm like okay it's not
just me it's it's like the actual
exchange and I was kind of freaking out
because I thought all right it's gone
I've already clicked by and and when you
when you were looking at the chart if
you look at the one minute chart it was
just going down like it went down down
down down and it just stopped you assum
yeah you'd assume that when it like
unfreezes it would have just kept going
down because who knows this was like a
black one event right so we don't know
what's going on and so that's why I was
like Frozen for a while cuz I thought I
just I'm an idiot I just lost all my
money but when it unfroze I saw I was up
like
$40,000 I was was I was like I like my
hard was you and yeah I think you went
on coinbase you'd be a when you told me
I was like I was like come on man I was
like but wait what what's the price and
I went and I went and bought 25k that
day too yeah and so which is actually an
amazing trade like we made more money in
that we made more money in that one
minute yeah then we did like you know
six months of experiments together you
know whatever you three months of
experiments we were working on at the
time and there is a lesson there which
was like um you know the the best kind
of like ideas don't all just from your
head like you know you're at the time
like intern Chief of Staff but you were
like this is a buy right now I'm going
to do this and by following you I kind
of like got the benefit of that at the
time and you know Bitcoin would traded
up to like 70 grand or whatever since
then and you come back down to Earth but
my my takeway from still 10x from that
day yeah my takeaway was uh there's like
there's a very few moments where you can
make all the money versus like trying to
make a little bit of money every single
time and I think like I'm not a day
trader I don't think I'd go back to
being a day trader or whatever but I
think all the money is made when there's
like a few key decisions that happen
maybe once a year or once every few
years once every few months whatever it
is um and you just have to act on it
with like it's a bit degenerate you have
to like there wasn't a lot of thoughtful
planning around I'm going to buy Bitcoin
because of this mathematical equation
that's full it was just times like this
doesn't happen every right the time me
in the moment I was like this guy's a
[__] degenerate right like I didn't
even know exactly how an option trade
worked I was like okay this is crazy but
at the same time you're right like if
you go read that Buffett quote where
he's like you know there are moments or
Seasons where you know the the the
clouds fill the sky and it's and it's
about to rain and in that he says in
that moment let us not come out with
spoons but bathtubs to sort of like make
hey there's also you know nval has a
quote that's similar to this which is
he's talking about luck is one of the
versions of luck is being able to
recognize an opportunity yeah so it's uh
it's the version of luck it's like he
calls it level two whatever or he's not
the inventor of this I I just heard it
from him um but you know the original
guy who wrote this he basically says you
know it's sort of luck favors the
prepared mind yeah so anybody could have
seen that price and most people when
they see something going down they get
scared you were like this is Bitcoin
Bitcoin flash crash blink decision that
this is a good bet for me like
whatever risk reward adjusted yeah and
uh you know you were correct in that
later I'm going to tell a story so you
come to the states we fly you out and uh
I remember we go to a restaurant and we
invite my buddy suie and we're talking
and Si's like okay Sean like you know
tell me like what what are you excited
about yeah and uh you go oh I'm excited
about this company called Annie mocha
and you had told me about this company
three times at this point and you were
like I love the stock anding mocha I
like the stock it was like you were like
the GameStop guy right you're like I
like the stock and I was like Annie
mocha I've never heard of this sounds
like a yogurt um and then I was like why
do you like it and then you told me
something I didn't really ask but I was
like what does it do and you're like oh
they're making these like bubble games
or something like that okay whatever
later when we're at this lunch I was
like Hey suly built a mobile gaming
company and sold it for whatever 100
million bucks more um tell them about
that what's that Mobile gaming company
and you started telling him he's like
okay interesting so I heard it like four
times from you never took action because
again I was not at that time listing in
probably the way I should have that's an
investment you made millions of dollars
off of yeah tell the story of how after
we stop working together you go from
intern to multi-millionaire in a very
short like how long like yeah it's very
foot B of time so at so I've known about
anaka it was a Australian listed company
so it was on the stock market and
initially bought like a few thousand
worth and it did well it went up like 4X
something like that so I was like okay
great that's you know I've done I've
done my done my thing here and and I I
was looking at it as an investment so I
didn't sell it and then the Australian
stock exchange they came after it and
they were like ah you guys are dealing
this weed crypto stuff we're going to
have to deist you well they weren't
crypto initially they pivoted to yeah
yeah so what about the time when I
bought so I bought them initially
because they had an announcement and
they were like we're going to do a thing
called crypto kitties um and we're going
to work with them and so I saw that as
like this was before like a pretty
boring robot company now it's like a
sexy crypto yeah it's like a sexy crypto
thing it's like how do you value a
blockchain game like this is like think
things that are like hard to value is
kind of what I like because nobody knows
what the price is and so like as of the
generic I like that um and so yeah so
anyway it did well none of this episode
is financial advice this is actually NFA
yeah me just laughing at the craziness
of the story so so let's let's tell the
story so you buy you buy more so yeah so
I bought it it got delisted and so I'm
like holy [__] my money is gone how much
were you in at that point uh it wasn't a
lot it was like 25,000 that behave yeah
but to you that was a lot that that was
yeah that was everything to me yeah so
you put you put everything you have
which is 25 Grand at the time it gets
delist off the stock exchange because
the exchange is like you guys now do
crypto we don't know we don't like
crypto we don't know what crypto is yeah
now your liquid stock you can't even
sell yeah I can't sell it um and so this
was like you tell me this I'm laughing
at you I'm like yeah I remember you told
me this you're like dude I got [__] on
Anoka and you're like it's delisted I'm
like wow I thought you probably just
lose money cuz the stock goes down I
didn't think you would lose money cuz
you just can't sell it anymore yeah but
you did something even crazy you double
down on crazy so tell so throughout that
year I did a few things I learned about
like secondary markets that's something
I didn't you know wasn't really exposed
to before I learn about that um I did a
lot more research into like what they
were doing and I've always been in the
and I was the perfect person because I
you know I had a Minecraft server when I
was a kid so in high school so I
understood how uh if you turn these
in-game items into something that you
could sell um this is a win-win for for
everyone so there's that I was a game
around H when you when you and I was in
Bitcoin way long before we 2016 so when
you mix all of that together I was like
the perfect person to see the white I
was like okay what they're doing is
actually something that I want to get
more exposed to and you know why buy a
bunch of different tokens and companies
but I can just buy the get exposed to
the people that I think will be the the
overall winners here
um and so once I you know got had that
conviction I was like okay well how do
how do I I can't Market buy the stock
right so I was like how do I actually
buy this thing now and this was like a
year it's been the listed so in that
time um I was working for you and and
another guy and I had a few other bets
that did off to pay was one of them that
ended up being you told me about that
one too yeah you we were talking about
buying out pay later yeah and I had met
uh Max El from a firm yeah I was like oh
this was a great startup idea and you go
oh we have actually afterpay is better
yeah and I was like bro your little
Australian version is not better you
were like no look at these numbers it's
better and uh that stock just went that
went from you told me like really early
on that one so I yeah yeah so uh I did
yeah so I did really well with that um I
also have a pretty crazy story there
where I followed one of the like I
didn't have a Lev of edge being like a
kid from Australia investing in a public
stock so I followed you know all the
seet people on straa to see where
they're at and um one of them was like
near the square officers and they never
like so that's when um you know they
ended up acquiring so I got like the
little Edge Millions so that was uh that
was like a little happy you're like I
don't have satellites to track cars but
you that's legit you follow the gun he
was at the square offices you're like
they might get bought so as a guy from
afterpay um the C was at he was in San
Francisco and he was like pretty close
to square off is doing his run and I was
like this there might be something I
didn't know what was going to happen I'm
like I feel like a pish would happen
with then you know Square came out and
bought them for like 30 billion or
whatever and you know the stuff going
way crazy but um anyway I made a bunch
of stuff I money from doing trades like
that um and working for you guys all
right so how do I buy anim I want to buy
more and you know the way I went to like
Facebook groups initially you told me
you were like there's a Facebook group
of people just like commiserating it's
like wailing recovering uh Anoka
stockholders were just there bitching
and moaning like they were very
disgruntled like they were talking about
doing like like a class action against
animok or whatever like all this stuff
and so I was like okay this like at the
time when they were listed they were
worth like 80 million or $100 million I
was like okay I could get a huge
discount on that um and so yeah I went
to Facebook I got a few people and
they're like small trades I was like I
need bigger how do I get like people
that have the big money so I got the
list of the top shareh holders you can
you can request it publicly in Australia
mightbe the same here in the States but
I got the top holders and I was like let
me go through each one of them which one
of them is disgruntled and and there was
a few that I I still couldn't like the
Australian press wanted me to like name
these people um I think one of them
favorite public but they like pretty big
time people that I mean they're already
rich M yeah they're smart money they're
already rich they had this because they
invested in some fund had some
allocation blah blah blah so they were
like just willing to get rid of it they
like it's Dlisted they don't know they
probably don't know that they're in
crypto or they're gaming it's just one
of the things in their portfolio that's
you know and so so you buying it for
like what discount like 80% it was more
like 80 90% discount to with the last
and I remember when you told me I have
the slack messages when you told me I'm
buying it for you know 10 cents on the
dollar yeah and I'm like bro you're just
lighting money on fire like you're going
crazy like what's gonna like that's a
insane reaction to the Bad News Bears
was I'm GNA like double
down but it worked I didn't I think I D
down I yeah I put everything I had is
about a 100k that I just like all right
this this should work out well it's also
like I'm if I lose all this money all
right I'm in my 20s I'll like you told
me this you go you're like I'm 20 years
old yeah I'm just gonna I'll just like
get a job and I'll save up again and
I'll I'll just I've got this is the time
to do every take all these crazy bets um
I don't have kids I don't have anyone
that's heads on me so uh yes I made the
BET um I did all the transactions that
itself was like a bit of a crazy thing
cuz they take some time to do to do
private transfers in Australia like the
documentation for that um the people
that that were handling the transactions
they were taking a long ass time so one
of them actually the biggest transaction
after Anoka you know announced their now
worth a billion dollars they did a raise
I was like do I even have these shares
because it was still it was still taking
time to process I'm like I put the money
in the Esco account like I obviously
ended up getting the shares but yeah it
was like the this whole new world of all
right I couldn't like I wasn't like an
angel investor before I didn't
understand how to do this so I had to
just like claw did they even know you're
like did these guys know they're dealing
with like a 20-year-old counterparty and
these no like they had no clue that they
were yeah that was yeah it was pretty
like these are these are like pretty
serious legit guys that were I mean they
thought they were you know shoveling
dirt onto me and then I was they're
probably laughing yeah yeah their
perspective was let me give dirt to this
person and I thought I was buying a gold
mine and so I was like all right let me
let me do this um but I remember I and
it a lot of this there's a lot of luck
involved obviously um and so when I
bought it you know I thought this was
like a very long-term play like after
five years there might be something here
um but it was only after about 3 months
so I bought it the valuation I bought
out was like 30 40 million and a few
months afterwards they raised a billion
dollars um and I remember getting a call
there was like this Hong Kong fund that
reached out to me and cuz I you know I
always I had to like Flex little bit of
people and put online that you know I
bought this company so you're up 58 X
yeah I'm up yeah it was it was worth
like I think $2 million um and I was
like holy [__] um let me like let me
like I'm not let me like have a think of
what to do here because people wanted to
buy it and yeah had a Hong Kong that
reached out was like we'll buy all of it
we'll give you $2 billion today you're
20 21 years old or something this was
actually right before they um actually
announced they're raising a billion
dollars some fund probably heard they
were going to rais a billion dollars
then were trying to get it off me at a
like at a discount so I was like I I
think they initial off was like a
million dollar or like whatever and I
remember calling my dad I was like holy
[__] like this is worth a million doll
and OB like grandparents you know this
is a million you took this to jro but
like take the money like what are you
doing take the money right now um and so
but you said I was like just wait a few
months maybe this will be more I was
like I was like I I don't think that
like this is it here and especially
because I was tracking all the numbers
especially nft like volume like nft
volume sales and I've been tracking this
every single month and for like it was
like a flat line it was like someone was
dead here and then in this month there
was a little uptick so I'm like this
these little upticks don't just like
start and here there's there's some like
craze that goes on here so I was like if
this is worth a billion dollars now and
this this the hype is just starting now
let me like ride this way at the peak
Anoka was worth what at the peak uh they
raised the latest R was six billion six
billion so you were buying in
effectively like a 2030 million
valuation yeah it runs up to 6 billion I
remember at one point you're telling me
in slack you're like these people just
offered me 2 million bucks for this yeah
I'm like holy [__] you did it we started
the podcast my first million you just
made your first two million congrats
like I can't believe this worked out
you're like I'm not going to sell though
and I was like wow this guy's insane and
I was like that's an insane story so you
held it um what's it at now uh who knows
no one knows I mean I was with uh I met
I met Yad and I met the bo it was a few
weeks ago in Sydney um and the the real
thing here is I I forgot who said it but
they were like never count your winnings
unless it's like cash in bank it's
realized um and so I was like okay you
have to exit this and the way to exit it
is either I sell it privately leag um
all these unicorns they're at massive
discounts right now so it's like I could
do that I like you know at its peak it's
worth eight figures do I sell now for
seven figures and and cash it in that's
always like a decision that plays L mind
otherwise you know they have plans to
list into do an IPO and what did you
told me at the time because I was like
dude this is say I was like hey man
listen yeah as your pseudo father father
figure here you should sell this and you
were like I see what you're mean but you
were like what I what do I need 2
million dollars for you were like I
don't have something I'm going to go do
I'm not going to change I don't want to
change my lifestyle like I like my
lifestyle yeah you were like I'm just
going to look to invest it somewhere
else and if I think this is still the
best place to invest it I'm just going
to do that and like you know if I lose
it I'm So Young that like whatever I get
the story and I'll just keep going like
you know I'm not and the way you said it
like the my meter went from oh my God
this guy's insane to like honestly I see
his perspective which is that two
million bucks changes most people's
lives but you were like I don't think
that that doesn't get me where I'm
trying to go yeah and in fact uh you
know if I still believe in this I just
want to see where this goes and for you
know for a while as crypto as nfts you
right became the thing that year yeah uh
you know there was sort of like a peak
moment in that where it became worth
more than $10 million right so like
would have played out very well timing
is always very very tricky um do you
look at this as I was trying to try I
was trying to time a a bubble or do you
look at this as I believe in this
company and I still believe in this
company and that's why I have the stock
believe in the company and also um I was
kind of seeing this as like there's
there's like a few people that have like
these life holds it's like uh you know
you hold these like this is a lifetime
hold this isn't like you buy in you sell
out whatever um and I was convincing
myself off that it's like I I'll buy
this and you know when this becomes like
the next 10 cent I'll have a couple
hundred million dollar stake and that's
how and I didn't have to do this is like
the only investment I had to do I didn't
have to make all these other Investments
um there's still some like part of me
that believes in that it's like I I
still see a pathway where like in the
next 20 20 30 years whatever this is
like 100 200$ 300 billion dollar company
or whatever and it's like I have I've
got a pretty decent you know stake in
that um and so yeah that that's what I
was like convincing myself of that is a
bit less now during times like this but
I still have some thing here where I'm
like okay um is it hard to not just get
attached like identity wise to like I
don't want to be wrong yeah I've made
that mistake before like I think you
know especially this is such an extreme
case it's one specific thing you were so
right you were boy Genius yeah then it
crashes but you're like am I now boy
idiot or am I boy Genius is this the
moment where I held through the tough
times or yeah did I just [__] up and I
need to learn that lesson like yeah
really hard yeah how you deal with that
well I think um well I went into let me
just like do something um so I was like
I was still investing some money on
behalf of other people and I was going
around and meeting meeting Founders and
stuff like that and that's why I'm like
I'm doing something else right now so
well okay yeah you have other bets yeah
I've got other bets so that's what got
me through it I was like if this goes
away I need to make sure that this is
the next big bet um I don't need to be
like I don't need to be right on this
one um like f you know if it ends up the
way it's going I could I've got time to
make more bets and right be really right
on something else yeah and also you had
done so much degenerate trading that
like you don't emotionally mood swing
like most yeah the money all actually
becomes PL money in a way well aside
from anaka I had a bunch of other token
Investments especially when when
Facebook renamed to meta um remember I
was buying up all the metav vest coins
to centraland axi sandbox and so I
experienced you know making millions of
dollars like liquid cash I also I
learned a lot of lessons there I also
lost a lot of that money when you know I
didn't manage my risk post post but I I
exper like the numbers just became like
you're looking at the screen I have no
attachment to it um there'll be like
those days where I'd be up a couple
hundred,
like holy obviously I spent a lot of it
I was like I you know all my boys were
treated well went out I when I eat we
all eat yeah it was like um I was a
pretty shy nerdy nerdy guy right so I I
didn't really know how to talk to girls
but if you want to learn how to talk to
girls get rich like I had it's like a it
was like a huge confidence boost so I
was yeah I was it just gives you the
conf it's just this the confidence for
you yeah I think it was a confidence it
was like even if she rejects me I'm
still I can go look at my metab Bas
later and feel good if was yeah it was
it was more like yeah and also for me
like having $2 million at a bank felt
like a billion dollars to me I'm like
I'm spending a lot and it's just like
it's not going down because because I'm
like I don't have kids I don't have
family I don't have any I have no
obligations whatsoever um even a lot
didn't put a big de would you what do
anything stupid uh so yeah I got an
apartment I got to I go to Tesla um I
spent like there' be weekends where I'd
get like limers app for me my boy would
get like like AR like for my birthday we
got like three Lim as we drove down to
the go which is like you know what go is
in Australia um I so happy to hear this
CU When I like I don't know what I was
paying you back then it wasn't much it
was like the the very first thing was it
was 30k a year I think it was we started
30k I think it went up after that yeah
to maybe like 80 to 100 something like
that that's what I was paying you then
and that I remember at the time being
like oh this is not going to work this
guy's getting like super rich doing
these like crazy Investments on the side
like yeah it's not going to make sense
for him to have a job at some point
which is great like my goal wasn't to
have you work for me for 20 years it was
like here's a young entrepreneurial guy
come get some reps with me come like
just get you off the traditional path
yeah and then like I hope you go do big
[__] and like you know I can be your
biggest fan and all that that's kind of
What's Happen there and I'm yeah I've
had my popcorn you know watching
watching you do this stuff and it's
being totally entertained the whole way
because you definitely like had like a
roller coaster um you're kind of like
those like Wall Street BS kids basically
like yeah I was on bets like since I was
in like high school like I was yeah I
was always on that for there's the
equivalent in Australia um there's a
thing called hot copper which is like
the equival of Wall Street bets and on
that I was like the most active person I
got and my nickname was Mr Silicon
Valley because I was just investing in
tech stocks right and I'm like if you go
on my everyone can look at my profile
it's like I'm oh I'm tweeting about Adam
moer I'm like talking about Adam moer on
that platform and there's another
company called brain ship ended up
becoming like a multi-billion doll
because the AI craze and stuff like that
um I was constantly looking at anything
to do with what is like the next 100x
Stu because for me it's Stu right invest
he told me some story a billionaire
takes you out to lunch and it's like
what's the next Anoka he reads the
article and he's like I gotta meet this
whiz kit takes you out he's like what's
the next one yeah yeah yeah you [__]
your pants immediately you're like I
don't [__] know yeah because during
that time like I'm I mean this is Zep
era right so I'm like everything I'm
telling people to invest in it's going
up and up and up and um you know I'm a
yeah I'm a genius um and so I was like
oh [__] but I truly belied I was like ad
could just raised a billion I was like
you should you should invest in adamka
Adam MOA is the thing that's that is the
next thing and he was like okay whatever
blah blah blah and in the next few days
but inside he's like God damn I love
that confidence yeah next few days he
ended up becoming like the top 10
shareholder in the company bought out
tens of millions of dollars off the
stock and then obviously you know an
stop at a billion you so he made you
know over nine figures in that um so
then that's a little bit on the on the
way out or tip the dealer or no there
that comment fair fair enough so um all
right so you go through that crazy
Journey one of the things that comes out
of that was you were then on behalf of
this guy plus other people you were
doing other Investments yeah one of them
is Shuffle let's talk about Shuffle so
yeah um you had slacked me a while back
and you were like hey crazy story I
think on the pot I was like can't say
who told me this right yeah now it's all
now it's like way more
at the time you were like hey there's a
company called steak yeah that is making
unbelievable amounts of money you were
like they had like a whatever $800
million dividend last year like that's
just that's the profits they took out
you're like this guy one of the owners I
how old are they they're like they're in
the like late 20s mid 20s yeah like 27
years old bought a $50 million house in
Australia yeah and another guy bought
like a whatever $100 million house and
it's like that's how you know someone's
like Rich by the way when they're yeah
buying like go look at the real estate
yeah that is like you with a buying
asset like that like people didn't know
it the articles are basically like
mystery you know Mega millionaire buys
$50 million home and then it was like
they had two companies they had like a
software company that makes
like for yeah it's like makes like the
gaming software to go play like the
games and then they have stake which is
the casino the like basic crypto casino
and they're like you know intertwined
companies or whatever yeah little Alam
uh you know FTX fish you know I'm
getting some Vibes here as I describe it
all loud but either way like steak has
been you know it's become like huge you
know they have Drake playing and and
whatever gambling and [__] like that so
you meet these guys who are doing a
competitor to that in a way yeah um how
do you describe Shuffle and tell us
about like this crazy space because I
only know what you told me about the
steak thing at the time yeah and then
since a bunch of news has come out like
kind of validating what you said um tell
me about the space and tell me well at
the time S I was so I was traveling
around just Australia meeting other
Founders and I was at this dinner and at
that dinner the guy there was a guy
there that was uh like pretty good
friends with the state co-founders and
he would like say these numbers this is
before the Articles and stuff like that
so he would say some insane bat [__]
crazy numbers and I'm like if these
numbers are true this is the fastest
growing Tech startup in Australia in
history like this is maybe in the world
like this is like very I mean they were
founded in 2017 and they're going to do
a couple billion dollars in Revenue this
is like some kids in their 20s right so
initially heard of that I was like okay
and then already at that time I I
remember messaging you about I wanted to
start like a crypto trading like let
people do like I want to start a I think
I titled the document I want to build
like the world's largest casino right
and um I remember this do yeah and the
way that that product is actually like a
huge product down um I don't know if
you've heard of R bit but they have like
a cryptos trading thing I was looking to
do that but that's like regulatory just
like a nightmare um it's like an
unlicensed thing and and so I was like
okay but I see this gambling stuff it's
it's huge stakers you know they just did
a billion dollars a net profit um in you
know single year how do I get some
exposure to that um and this going back
to like how I find these opportunities I
just remembered there was another like
hidden uni that lived in a whole
different cityy in Australia that posted
his research on afterpay and this was
like a couple of years ago and I don't
know why he popped out in my mind again
so I went looking for that article I
found his name and I uh hit him a
message on link like hey like you know
what are you doing these days um let's
catch up and whatever and yeah we caught
up and then that's when he started
telling me about like these other crypto
kids in Australia that have like made it
pretty big doing all this degenerate
stuff and they're starting a crypto
casino and it's going to be a competitor
to not to stake but there's like that's
the thing the market is so huge there's
I could you know there's there's a few
other competitors are also doing a
billion dollars um and it's just not
really reported on right it's kind of
like a uh yeah kind of shady industry so
I was like okay I for me you know coming
from pretty small town in Australia when
when you meet other people that are kind
of like you and we all had a like
success in our own domain I'm like if we
just come together we're going to hit
something big um and I just wanted to be
around those people um and so it was
more like a bet on this group of yeah
just like also ambitious smart slightly
degenerate or very degener autistic yeah
like 20 20y olds basically yeah and
these old people and we've all we've all
kind of been through the same thing of
making a lot of money losing a lot of
money so we can kind of like lean on
each other in that way like they we
understand each other in in that so um
by the way this happens in like it's
happened in online pover I remember like
the rise of online poker and the kind of
Poker kids who all made it and they all
kind of lived at houses together and
yeah figured out how to like each like
beat the game together basically uh same
thing happened with social media so like
the Tik tokers or the viners who all
went and live in the same building in
Los Angeles collabed with each other
plus traded tips plus like got brand
deals for each other and they all like
rose up way faster than the people who
were on their own or didn't have the
kind of connection this was my juner
yeah so um yeah so that that's how I met
them but I was like we all kind of
agreed a lot of the background of the
shuffle team they come from like the big
exchanges FDX is one of them bitmax
crypto.com that's all their backgrounds
so
the Harvard uh Stanford of the uh of the
sketch world I was like we we all and
you know obviously I've traded on all of
them and we all just had like we all
agreed on this macro thesis of every
single cycle there is like this one
clear big winner which is the exchanges
right they their business model is every
bet every degenerate bet you take they
have a little fee right it's called
transaction fee for them for us it's
called hassard but it's the same exact
thing model the same model uh struck the
legal structure is actually really
similar as well they will like get a
license out in SEALS or or you know FTX
was Bahamas crypto casino is out in the
dut Caribbean and CA so it was like
there's all these similar what is that
there's like some place that's like they
just made it their business some some
country country right not yeah yeah yeah
Pur yeah that's the that's place where
the hell is Pura what is D it's just a
place uh where you can I mean anyone if
you want to get a license to do like an
online crypto Casino um you could
probably spin one up in like 6 weeks and
it's very and that's their model they
they're like we're open for business for
casin for online casinos basically and
like that's where everybody goes to get
their yeah we're like in the same
structure as Stak and you know all the
other guys um we're all under the same
license and there's some risk to that
obviously like what happens to that
license how long can you sort of play
this game and you have to uh you sort of
calculate what what amount of risk you
and take there but yeah that's that's
it's exactly the same as these exchanges
that were out out out um you know in the
stal or or behind and so we saw that and
we're like okay um here's a clear
difference between exchanges and casinos
though exchanges are raising at tens of
billions of dollars and that they've got
all the fame um whereas you know in if
people just understood if this was more
public on how profitable these casinos
are and how they're very similar
businesses to to exchanges then you know
there would be some reating or valuation
for these for these play for these
casinos and so that was like that's but
a lot of these investors and funds they
have like a no Vice Clause right they
just can't invest in weed they can't
invest in gambling or porn or whatever
even though there's money to be made
there so I think like that's one of the
other reasons is like yeah some people
just either themselves individually
morally say that or their fund Charter
basic prohibits them from doing those
things so they're just like out on even
if they know it's a great business I who
doesn't think a casino is an amazing
business we we we raised the seed route
and that was like the
hottest my biggest regrets was was not
investing I tried to invest and then
goes like Oh it's like one entity here
here and I was like oh God like if I
have other people's if it's my own money
fine but I when I have other people's
money you I have to like you know think
twice and just in that time it like
closed or whatever yeah but anyway like
that's we we all agree that uh in this
like next cycle whenever it is could be
five years down line who knows but in
the next cycle for crypto um we believe
that there will be one two or three
casinos in the top 20 of of all the
coins and that's billions of dollars of
of value that we think that you know we
could we could do and a big difference
with us is like like I'm on this podcast
right now like we're not Anonymous like
we're not like these people that like
all these crypto casinos usually they're
like very Anonymous people and um I mean
if you're putting your money into a
platform you want to know who's behind
it right you want to know who these guys
are but how do you um like all the how
you follow all the FTX stuff going on
right now I'm like really into this
trial it's like my soap oper right now
that I'm paying attention to it's your
Roman Empire that's it's my Roman Empire
exactly do you have you're following it
and also like
how do you feel about that how do you
think like because it seems like crypto
casino is like Risk times risk in that
sense of like I don't know something be
between you know malpractice to like you
know the craziness that comes with with
just that amount of money flowing
through something yeah um and you said
you have people that worked in some of
those places what did they I guess what
stories have you heard and I guess I
don't know like not like isan spokesman
uh you know like not you professionally
if we can just like my friend like the
how do you think about that stuff yeah
um it's like it's I mean being in crypto
already you already you have like an
appe Tye of speculation um and so anyone
that's already in the industry it's like
you're you're taking some you're taking
some risk on okay there is some like
regulatory risk already that one day
this this license might close down and
your business is like you know screwed
up like and so you have to be kind of
smart and calculated about that like
okay what are the other licenses can we
start build building that up like we
have to build our entire platform like
in a modular way so if something happens
to one license we can split off let's
say our casino and then put a license to
the sports book it Offroad in the
different regions so just like lost it's
like we had to move the island yeah L
like we moved it it's so uh so some
regulatory risk there some what's funny
like products have most startups have
product Market fit risk like we don't
know if anybody wants what we have to
offer yeah you have no Market risk then
the second tier is technical risk it's
like uh if we can make a um whatever
self-driving car right people are going
to want it there's no Market risk but
there's technical risk can you even
build a self-driving car yeah with this
there's no technical risk either right
it's like I mean obviously you have to
do technical work but it's not that's
not the risk in the business it's all
regulatory uh it's all regulatory risk
in this which is so different than like
99% of the other startups I look at yeah
very few times you just just get
regulatory risk there's also just like
actual risk that you have to manage of
your book like limits that you like we
will sweat sometimes like when we
because we have to start upping the
limits you know there some High Rolls
that com and go like we I want to do a
10K Blackjack hand I want do a 25k
Blackjack fan and you're just like okay
holy [__] we have to you know if they
have a few good runs it could be all of
a sudden down a couple hundred thousand
a day so your revenue is not always
guaranteed that's also like the biggest
difference in this in the talk about ATT
traction so you guys launch out on a win
in February of this year yeah what's the
what could you share attraction wise uh
so you know going to do a half a billion
in volume like this month um and you
know this is generating a few million in
Revenue a month uh and hopefully this
month will be a few million of profit a
month and you know we this is also
another thing that like these businesses
are built to strip out the cash flow
it's like you you you build the business
and then you have you pay this out this
is not like you're not praying for some
exit we all went into it knowing that no
one's going to buy a crypto Casino you
build it to make a lot of money and and
you know stri stri the strip the money
out um and pay it out to all the holders
of the business so um that's also like
yeah it's a very like yeah it's great
yeah it's a good problem to so yeah it's
only been a couple months but um yeah
it's yeah probably 50 million run ratees
probably where we're at right now super
impressive crazy um any good stories
about like I don't
know how did you bootstrap where did you
go get your first customers how did you
because that was your job yeah yeah so
cuz you'd be like in [__] Asia right
now uh you know meeting people I'm like
what are you doing in Asia you're like
I'm I'm building the brand I'm figuring
out how to get this thing off the ground
well this is like a
really the the first thing that I I
don't know why I didn't really know this
but the people that come in play on your
site if they like to gamble you know
they probably also have some other VI
and like they're probably not some of
them are probably you know can get very
angry very easy the whole thing is about
either you make money or lose money so
when they make money obviously they're
happy when they lose money you know this
place especially this Beyond like I'm
going to find out where you live and I'm
going to find out like so that was like
the when you talk about your first 10
customers like your first 10 customers
are pretty rough people that you have to
do so um I mean the first thing we went
to was we're all a bunch of crypto kids
that made a bunch of money and then we
gambled it ourselves so like we already
had a lot of other crypto kids that made
a bunch of money and you know like to
gamble so we went to those guys first
and like hey come come you know plan our
website and and test it out and we would
you know there's little tricks and stuff
of like stuff with like deposit bonuses
and like like standard kind of sport
standard like sports play motions and
stuff like that um one thing that I
think we did that was or that that's
pretty interesting that we found out was
okay we should stop spending so much
time trying to get thousands of people
who will deposit like1 $20 or whatever
because they'll come on they'll come on
your side and it's good for them to you
know play but they will lose $5 and then
you know know spend 48 hours in your
support you know I'm going to kill you
where where do you guys live I need my
$5 back versus like okay let's let's
maybe try and find customers that are
you know not like that and we got pretty
lucky in some parts of Asia especially
Japan right like they are they are
people who bet really big and they're
very respectful and they're very like
they don't waste any of our time like
they will lose money play with honor
yeah so it's like okay these are the
customers we want now we know the
customers that we want and that's good
for the business um and yeah we started
making some pushes there and and trying
to find uh you know this is a pretty
heavy like affiliate business you want
to find you want other people to go out
and do the work because you can't do
Facebook we can't do Facebook lives
we're prohibited from doing Google so
you can't do PPC so you have you have to
find really creative ways of trying to
acquire customers and yeah that that was
yeah well this is why like stake I think
bought or they created kick yeah and
they're basically like paying twitch
streamers you know jobs of money
reportedly like 50 million1 million
contracts to come play because they're
like oh these are popular people one of
the things they'll play is we'll give
them money to gamble on our platform
they gave Drake like tens of millions of
dollars of like go play show people that
you're doing a $20 million vent yeah and
or you know gambling $20 million one
night it makes you look like a baller it
creates great content that's going to go
viral and get you likes yeah and all
those people are going to see that
gambling on stake is fun and Drake
doesn't right that's like their is that
accurate that's my perspective so St
pioneered that mod like they like uh we
can't bid on these other channels with
all these other crypto or like other
casinos um and so let's try and find
other ways and the streaming model like
they behind
thatly the thing that's genius about
also is that instead of like an
influencer posting a picture saying hey
come play on stake they're playing the
product they're showing you how Works
you're seeing their
reaction picture with the whole thing so
it's not only are you educating people
about how to play it and how to like
this like next level in terms of um I
guess like play of value as well like
like they will deposit and you know
they'll play they'll lose and one
they're watching their favorite streamer
play again they're like all right time
for me to also deposit again so we found
out like the Affiliates or the
influencers that are really like they
have a Discord Channel or they yeah they
have a you know they're constantly like
live streaming those people make the
most M something you said like uh we
would not like rather than have you have
a million followers want you to have you
know 2,000 people like active in a
Discord that you talk to all the time
that's more valuable right like and I I
think this doesn't just this isn't just
for like a casinos I think like for Ecom
and know like there's people that do
Facebook groups and right anywhere
there's like a concentrated like you
have like those thousand you know loyal
fans or whatever um those customers are
worth yeah all the money we did a
influencer campaign we spent
$100,000 on influen probably the first
like paid influence campaign we' done
yeah so we put up I was like let's try
$100,000 and we're going to spread that
across these like I think we did um
seven influencers I think right and so
these are people who have like you know
let's call it 250,000 to like three or
four million followers on
Instagram and I sh you not some people
some of those people who have a lot of
followers literally had zero conversion
zero like dude I could post on Facebook
and get one conversion like it's crazy
some people kicked ass and as like
what's the difference I noticed that you
know Instagram has this one feature
which is like when um not everybody has
it but like you can broadcast so like I
don't know if you've seen this but like
instram has this like almost like one to
many group chat you can send a message
and they can only Emoji react they can't
like it's not like your fans can chat
back but it looks like a chat right and
I noticed that the people who have
active versions of those where they'll
just be like oh you know my favorite mug
yeah and it'll get like 3,000 like likes
there right that's a way better signal
for who actually converts versus like
just a generic post or story or follower
count yeah which is like you know
neither here or there and people that
really move product you can tell like
the difference in it it's also just
about uh them being like very high
intent and so I think about the people
that would go into that broadcast
channel in the first place it'd be like
a small percentage of like that person's
like most loyal like fans or whatever
that are active and you know yeah so I
think um for like that that could be
applied everywhere uh wherever you can
like who cares about trying to get you
know 4 million impressions I just want
to get I want my product in front of
like the Thousand most I keep using the
word degenerate but not degenerate but
like you know whatever the thousand
people that are by the way I use
degenerate positively too when we were
hiring we used to you know companies
have like corporate values yeah and it's
like Integrity yeah and um honesty and
like like everybody has the same values
it's like don't kill somebody or
something I don't know ours was
degeneracy yeah and people were like why
does it say you should be a degenerate
to work here and we were
like that's what it is like that's what
we want we want people who who like when
they work on some like there's Just Two
Types of People there's some people that
like you know they work to live and some
people live to work right like right we
are the types that when we do a project
we go all in we love doing it we obsess
over making something [__] awesome
that's going to take a lot of work and
late nights we don't want to feel like
we're uh like asking for a favor every
time we try to go above and beyond to do
something cool like right and but it
wasn't about working hours only that was
just one aspect the other thing we used
to say is like we noticed that the
people who were the best earlier in
their life had a degenerate like
obsession with something that wasn't
like the thing your parents would reward
you for or the school would reward you
for it right so for a lot of people it
was gaming it's like oh yeah I just
spent like an ungodly amount of hours in
in Ultima 4 or like you a Runescape or
something like that that was such a
strong signal to us that like this
person is going to be great now with us
because they have that switch where once
they get really into something they
practice to like to master it and they
get obsessed they want to beat the game
and like they're not doing it for the
because people told them to do this
they're they're doing it because they
can't not do it yeah and so we found
that people who had early obsessions in
life were the best people that we wanted
to work with you also want that in
customers or an influencer who's got
people that are Die Hard fans like why
do people love Taylor Swift like
swifties they just they identify in that
tribe is what want yeah and I think that
like whether people like the idea of a
crypto Casino or that makes them feel
like really crazy or whatever I think
that the marketing lesson about how
these guys Market themselves it's like
one of the best like marketing hacks
that created a multi-billion dollar
outcome was this one realization that
hey let's pay these influencers and
celebrities to specifically do live
streaming on Twitch was not the main
marketing channel right for 99% of other
brands and let's give them money to
gamble so that people can watch the the
sort of thrill of victory and the agony
of defeat yeah live in real time and
that is the best marketing for our
product I respect I also think for those
guys I think they're really they're like
one of the most like fascinating
entrepreneurs that come out of Australia
because I think for kick it's not it's
actually I think their goal here is all
right they've now you know made this 5
to10 billion like crypto Casino it's
like where's this they want to go more
now this you know twitch was valued at
40 50 billion I think these guys
legitimately just want to go in and you
know although they use the money to be
twit they want yeah they want to use
money to like this is their next thing
to get them to like I think they want to
leverage they were already working with
all these streamers paying them you know
millions of dollars to gamble it's like
well let's actually just also pay you
guys Millions dollars to stream but on
our platform it's like I think they saw
uh a sort of Gap here they came at the
right time um but I yeah I don't think
it's just for gambling I think these
guys truly um you know love there's no
way that works because streaming doesn't
make that much money
yeah yeah there is no way that that
works in the sense that uh you know they
would really have to be betting that
they could and you know okay so I don't
think it could work but here's the case
where it maybe could so I remember so
Tik Tok now is obviously massive yeah do
you remember when Tik Tok came out so
like yeah it was musically and then they
did like a musically and musically was
doing good but didn't like make it to
like the full mainstream and it was kind
of still seen as this like kitty lip
sing kind of it wasn't like Tik Tok
today you can go learn [__] you can you
people make you laugh you can promote
your business you can sell products you
could you do anything at the time
musicly was literally like tween girls
lip sticking right that's like all it
was right there like more of what the
more of what the product was so then
they Rebrand a t it's like they get
bought they Rebrand a Tik Tok which like
I remember laughing about the name like
what is that name and they literally
spent a billion dollars marketing that
app to make sure every teenager has it
installed on their phone yeah and like I
we had a kid who was working for us at
the time that was in high school but he
would come and work at our office I was
like dude what do your friends think of
Tik Tok he's like ah it's like the joke
but he's like I got to say like
everybody knows Tik Tok he's like
there's not one pet person in my school
that doesn't know Tik Tok he's like we
don't think it's cool yet but like I got
to give it to him like 100% of every kid
in my school is aware that there's a
tikt app that they want you to download
yeah and like they actually Brute Force
like created the network effect I guess
there's a world where K could do that
but it's also I think you're banking on
um maybe they do something where the
friction to buy something on live
streaming is lowered and yeah that's a
whole new like Avenue I I think there I
think they know that the traditional
model is not going to ever work and that
let's just get all the eyeballs and then
maybe they can flick some switch
somewhere um and you know like Instagram
reals makes like $10 billion a year I
don't know
how like you plugged into the world's
greatest ad engine in the world Facebook
ad engine is the greatest ad engine
maybe Google's one or two but like it's
PL the reals makes that much money
because it's plugged into one of the
greatest money makers ever um and live
streaming is live streaming Commerce is
like a pretty huge thing in Asia um and
so if it can if it can somehow work and
Western markets I think like there's
something I think there where they could
flick the switch and then you know this
is this is how they go from we're
already worth a couple billion dollars
how do we get to 10 20 50 and maybe they
don't care about how much they're worth
but what's like the
yeah what's like the next they've
already won one games like how do we how
do we get to the next so I think um yeah
that that's super like I think more
people should probably know about those
guys and are you like I'm gonna be a
degenerate forever or you like you know
I'm just going to do this for this
period and then I'm going to do
something else well I'm I'm just I
really wanted to be a part of something
that could be huge and that could grow
really fast um and so I I want to do
that with Shuffle and yeah ride this
wave um like will I do another thing in
sports betting or gambling whatever I
don't know you know maybe not but um I
like like I mentioned you ear before
it's like you make your nut and go to
your Noble Mission like I I think I
think I might just May's quote love that
love that quote um I love that quote not
because I think it's right but because
so many people when they hear that
they're like that's what I'm doing
because it's such an easy out to like
justify anything that you're doing in
the moment cuz you're like I'm going to
do the noble Mission later and so I love
it because it's hilarious how much
people love that quote I don't know if
it's good wisdom or bad wisd I could
tell but uh what by the way what uh
ideas do you have so yeah do you know
MFM you know that's what we do here I'm
gonna I'm gonna get out my nesop really
quick to and we might have already
talked about some just uh really quickly
there was um before we talking about
kids that were playing runes scap and
stuff like that I literally have already
W in here I had incubator around kids
who are building businesses within games
um I like that CU I think everying yeah
every so
I guess during my era like I'm I'm a bit
older now during my era it was kids that
were building Minecraft servers or um I
know for the guys that did stake they
were RuneScape kids they they built a
casino in RuneScape first and then they
did their own thing so it's like
RuneScape Minecraft I think now it's
like Roblox or like maybe um like
fortnite Creator maps and stuff like
that like if you're building businesses
within games um every single person I've
met that's done that they're all like
super successful millionaires I 100%
agree I think I tweeted this out I
what people think a su the like winners
backgrounds looks like yeah and you know
what the world tells you it's like you
know good grades it goes to a good
school has good internships and like you
know uh after school activities runs for
student counsil BL it's like what I've
seen is like what the real winners are
are like the kid the guy who's running
his own gaming server when he's 14 yeah
kind of because he just wants to be able
to buy games he's not like even running
it as a business right like the sneaker
head like sneaker flippers basically um
you know people that are like hardcore
Gamers that are like become best in the
world at a video game that's like super
competitive yeah thatp and like you know
which requires skill strategy
communication like ton like Obsession
those are pretty translatable skills
yeah uh you know speech and debate is
another one like there's these like un
unorthodox backgrounds RuneScape is one
that's crazy the RuneScape Mafia the
number of rich young people I've met
that the Comm denominator is yeah we
used to be like I I didn't play
RuneScape but they're like yeah
RuneScape has like the the marketplace
or the plaza or something yeah and they
were like yeah we used to R we used to
run the plaza or the marketplace and I
was like gez this is something I have an
idea around that which is uh I was like
I want to create kind of like the
outcast conference so basically what I
want to do is be like these are actual
hot beds of talent that nobody's really
talking
about I want to invite like the people
who do that like your point of entry is
like you you need to hit one of those
crit you running gaming server or like
yeah you're like Elite at this like you
know I found this one thing called Mind
sport it's like some place you go that
you it's like Olympics but for nerds so
you don't do like you don't run you play
chess and then you play back gaming and
then you play like you play like this
like Advanced version of Chess like you
you play Go you play like all these
games and whoever's like the best across
these like 10 really hard strategy games
is like the Mind sport Champion Y and
you know that guy's a free you know
those guys are all going to be
as soon as they decide like oh okay it's
time for me to have a career now yeah as
long as they just get to like funnel in
the right place and don't just go be a a
Mackenzie drone like yeah you know those
people are going to kick ass so I'm like
oh I want I want to make a thing where
it's free for them to attend but you got
to be the best of the best and I want to
just be able to like curate that talent
and be like I'm gonna place my bets on
these people now like hey if any of you
ever start a company just remember this
Goodwill of me bringing you here paying
for all of this because I want to be
your first investor like yeah I
genuinely think that's going to be like
one of the highest Roi things that I
could do well I think a lot of them so a
lot of them get lost to like banking or
something like that and then um there's
a lot of them as well that they just
don't have guidance coming out of with
the first thing that they do and so they
[__] around for maybe like a few years
and then like that's I'm TR to Outcast
because like they probably feel like oh
kind of like kind a little bit I I
wasn't doing all the [__] that the other
like achiever kids were doing but like
no no no trust me let me show you 10
other people that are like you and
they're like oh I see myself in them
like I can do it too this this is the
basis of like a lot of sports like you
see a guy that's from your hometown and
now you start to believe you can do it
too why do you like Australian
entrepreneurs so much like what do you
care it's like because they're from
Australia I'm from Australia if they
made it I can make it that's that's cool
but had you never heard of any you would
probably also be you know banking
somewhere you know on that and also like
I think a lot of them when you spend
your time well your childhood whatever
like in a room doing all this stuff
you're whenever you're making money or
like you're learning business skills but
then you start lacking in other areas
like maybe so then like that that's
setting up setting yourself up for
failure to waste some time whe whether
it's then afterwards you know you have
some girl troubles or afterwards you
don't know how to do something with
family or whatever blah blah blah that
um yeah I think that that's why oh
that's a great idea at I'm just gonna
have a kissing I'm have a high girl like
yo if you haven't had your first kiss
just let's just do it now and we're
going to get that all out of the way
we're going to we're going to crush
these like lingering D in your head yeah
but yeah that that was one of them
um what was your idea was I the idea was
like just like a like a like a you know
giving these kids like mentorship and
like just
incat a little y combinator thing for
for these weirdos um what yeah there's a
I was just at a conference I was just
really surprised um I know something
within conferences where I think maybe
more people should uh make conferences
for like cash. niches um because
especially if you do like the exhibitor
model where it's like oh my God like you
know and some of these people are the
one I just went to they're paying a
couple hundred thousand dollars for for
for a Bruce so maybe that starts off as
you do your newsletter what you do like
the the L effort thing first a low price
low effort thing of newsletters whatever
build that audience and then just
immediately go into like I'm surprised
you guys haven't done a conference yet
because I feel like that would that
would make like an MFM one yeah like an
MFM La yeah um another one that actually
kind of related um I think this is kind
of boring but like a CRM for again like
cashed up niches so we're right now
looking for like a new CRM platform and
you know everyone goes to like
Salesforce whatever but they operate in
like a 100 different verical right and
so who's going to get our 10K a month
it's going to be the one that is BU yeah
built specifically for I gaming which is
our nich whatever so right now like
we're making a decision and we're going
to go with some other smaller we're not
going with Salesforce we're going with
this other one they're going to get out
you know Grand mon whatever um because
they specifically they specifically for
gaming um so that's like another one
that's a little bit boring but it's like
if you could just find like some Niche
one of these other cash up Niche so like
one for example I think is like farming
right yeah yeah I mean any real estate
is another one right yeah within that
you could even be like senior living or
right HVAC you know like things like
that where you know that everybody there
can spell iida right well it's like it's
I think for anything that were the
interactions or the behaviors of your
customer is very it's very high value
but it's also it's very different to
like maybe like an Ecom or whatever like
or like just a transaction like on our
one it's like you you have a bunch of
games that you like and you spend you
know we want to know exactly if you've
lost this amount of money in the next
few hours we want to like make some
contact with you and stuff like that we
can't really do custom behaviors like
that with like a sales force whatever
because or or like whatever else CRM
platform because it's it's very tailored
to a very broad Niche so anything that
has like saying high value customers and
then basically figure out like first
principles what should this look like
for this Niche yeah yeah I think
something like that like that' be a good
idea I think that's a very like that's a
very good sandbox for somebody that
wanted to explore and we we just watched
this before uh there could be someone
that does like so in in the gaming Biz
there's you know VIP like VIPs make up
your whole entire business of we're
talking about there's actually other
verticals as well where VI is like your
thing should actually every single
business probably has VIPs that they're
just like not uh interacting with um so
maybe like VIP median software for Ecom
right for whatever you know even for
like retail businesses or whatever like
you probably have yeah you probably have
like customers that will come in let's
say I I started getting into like the
hot cold exposure therapy stuff so I
started going like how Tech bro of you I
was like I started going into these
places like you know three four times a
week but um you know if these guys just
would have know that like I'm paying
this much amount of money come upsell me
on something else or do something else
like I think that even like retail
businesses like just if you were to
focus less of your time on trying to you
know broaden uh like getting you paying
on these Facebook ads to get the next
thousand customers what about the 10
that's going to spend like you know you
know whatever five 10 times more on the
business um so that's probably I think
some VIP management software for guys
that would be they could sit on top of
whatever whatever you choose it could
just sit on top of the current software
and just be like yeah but this one is
all about your VIPs and we're just going
to extract the data that we need and
then give you the actions or the
recommendations or the the triggers in
order for you to like when should when
should we reach out what should we give
them what do they like it's um that
could that could be one um this is
probably not so unique but I think I I
don't know if you use these use people
like this but like uh agencies for
Content that do it's like full service
of like thumbnails and um editors and
like I don't know how hard that is to
find like people that really know their
[__] about you know creating online
content cuz it seems like every single
person wants to like you know be a
personality or brand right now um and so
people that I mean a lot of these are
like uni kids that know how to do this
um but it's like exactly how to connect
those middle yeah be the middleman for
The Unique is like done for you so dfy
yeah so like people who do this Ecom now
honestly I think they're pretty scammy
but they're like hey will just hand you
an e-commerce business that makes cash
flow right it's like anytime someone
promises you passive income just like
run away yeah but like um that's what
they're promising and a lot of people
these companies that are promising this
are making a ton of money and one of the
reasons why is it's tempting to instead
of just saying here we'll teach you
Facebook ads but now you got to go
figure out the rest what product what's
the supply chain what's what's Google
ads they're like we're just going to
give you the whole thing yeah uh turkey
and so you know there's a version of
that like there's video editors and
content there there's you know
copywriters but like you kind of want
the whole thing the sort of like done
for you package yeah I think like a full
service uh Agency for all that sort of
stuff might might work out um trying to
think of what else uh me
see uh this one's kind of related to
like maybe uh what you're doing with
Shepherd but um so recently we like we
we s had to expand to Japan right um and
that is like none of us speak Japanese
like we don't know how to scale in that
country and so what what we had to do
was like first let me research what
other companies have done and I remember
reading I think maybe it was like a
chamar video when he was at Facebook and
he was like uh we hiir some NBAs and
they flew over to Japan they came back
and you know a few months went by we
went grown like what's going on we fired
those NBAs we got this like young woman
from that was actually living in Japan
and within the first month we're seeing
growth and we're like wait what okay
what are you doing that these NBA people
haven't done she is like well you know
on on the Facebook profile like we don't
care about your relationship status we
care about your blood type and it's just
like stuff like that that you would only
know localization not translation and to
find those people was like yeah it's
pretty hard to to do that so maybe if
there's some like agency where um like
so we hired uni kids that are that speak
native like fluent English so we can
communicate with them but also they're
fluent you know in Japanese and doing
that like you know out growth be like
tedex of just like they know the market
in terms of by none of them knew
anything about like gambling they don't
need to know that we can teach them that
right they need to know like what are
the people like how do you communicate
with them how do we uh yeah localize all
that content do everything um to to
cater to this Market where and it's it's
in certain markets very important that
you are respectful and you appear like
you're not you appear like you're not a
foreign company that's trying to attract
the customers you appear like you're
born out of that country right um so so
doing that whole process for me was very
hard to find like the right people that
spoke English that also was native in
Japanese and and knew all that so uh
maybe if there was some like Shepherd
like uh agency to help you okay you're
expanding into this country here's like
your you know growth assistance that are
need for that language and can do all
these things um that's cool I like that
um yeah there's two crazy things on that
one if you look at the Facebook growth
chart like one of the key things for
Facebook was getting the site translated
and localized across like and they did a
they had to do some crazy Wikipedia like
[__] to get the whole site translated
because there so many different I mean
the Facebook site was kind complex at
the time and so um I remember seeing
that that was very impressive to me
second is there's a sub version of this
which is just to do business in certain
places you have to establish an office
yeah um like China you can't do business
there unless you have a local office you
can't do business certain places can't
pay you can't pay local people unless
you have a thing or whatever and just
that can take like a year yeah and so
like I remember with TW when we're at
twitch it's like oh yeah we're trying to
put our servers here we're trying to do
this here um we're using we had to use
Amazon's people to do International
expansion because like twitch even as a
multi-billion dollar company didn't have
like that expertise in house right and
they would be like yeah it's going to be
12 months and they'd be like we're
finally live in whatever so and so
country with our office and I'm like
what and like and they're like that this
has been a year of effort I'm that's
insane like that seems like can we turn
that a software somehow like the way the
stripe Atlas did for company corporation
like is there a stripe Atlas for the
world in that way I've been a little
funny story about the localization stuff
so um like everyone probably listening
is probably thinking like oh but why
don't you just get AI to translate your
stuff and it's it's not there to the
point because we were using just chatu
PT a bunch of guys that were
non-japanese speaking chatu PT and you
know we're talking to like very high
value customers right and you know the
AI hasn't really caught up in like tone
or like certain like aners and so
apparently like you know we were talking
to a VIP like they were a kid like we
were saying good boy likeu like that and
yeah was yeah some people are into that
[__] yeah these people like and then you
know yeah definitely these people
definitely were they were like they stop
playing with us yeah like disrespecting
me blah blah blah so um yeah so getting
like native yeah getting like for
especially languages like that like
getting like native people to know how
to speak um yeah no work so what one of
the one of the projects I worked on when
I was at twitch was like we were trying
to grow like crazy in Brazil and so I
was like all right luckily we had a
group of people like there's four people
in an office in Brazil that like no one
was even talking to really they were
like yeah they were so at arms length
from headquarters and I was like hey I'm
here and you guys are like my key people
they're like oh awesome we have so many
ideas like can you help us do them we're
like yeah I was like what sorts of ideas
and they were like well you know are uh
everybody here uses YouTube and so
subscribe is like how you follow people
on YouTube but on Twitch subscribe is
you cost money so everybody here they
open the Twitch app and they click
subscribe to follow the someone they
find interesting it says pay $5 right
they're like dollars first of all five
that's a week of groceries yeah and
secondly this side you have to pay to
watch people screw this they don't even
know that it's free to watch right it's
like can you just change the text on
that button and I was like oh damn how
many more of those are there inside this
app and another one was like we were
like trying to come up with like these
marketing campaigns we like marketing
like our marketing experts like coming
up with these ideas I asked the little
team they were like hey can you buy the
can you just give me your credit card I
want to buy five iPhones I was like
iPhones why he's like in Brazil an
iPhone is like a gold bar it's like this
is like he's like we're just G to give
these away trust me it'll get like
20,000 people watching this stream I'm
like what he's like this is a gold bar
imagine somebody just giving out like
golden bars he just kept saying that he
did it and it was just exactly that was
like all of a sudden was just number one
most watched Guy on Twitch that day was
the guy giving away one iPhone and he he
milked it for like 4 hours he's like I'm
not giving it away until we get like
30,000 people in here yeah and he's like
and it worked it was insane yeah stuff
like that that we that we find out like
every week of like oh [__] you guys
actually do it this way and by us have
you heard about what Mr Beast does with
this uh is it like the dubbing videos
that so first he exploded his growth by
just being the one of the few American
YouTubers to like create his Brazil page
create his Philippines page create his
Indonesia page he created separate
account for all those localized them
hired somebody who speaks the language
and like you know like when we were over
hanging out with a some lady watched in
speaking Portugues and I was like like
yeah what the hell's going on and he's
like oh yeah she manages like my whole
page for for Brazil uh you know like you
have to have somebody who speaks the
language and knows it and then what they
did was I was like so do you dub it he's
like yeah we dub it but we hire like
voice actors I'm like why don't you you
could use AI I'm like excited to be like
you can use AI he go yeah yeah I'm sure
you can but like he's like what we do is
we go we find the guy who did the
Spider-Man voice in Brazil and he does
my dub for like pretty cheap and then
every comment is holy [__] it's
Spider-Man yeah and like he's getting
crazy engagement because they're like
that's Spider-Man and he's like yeah it
cost me like an extra five grand but
like look at what it did to my page I
think they turn that into like a agency
where they like like they do it for
other people as well like it's yeah they
do the D for you thing they're like yeah
if we did this for growth we should do
this for 20 other YouTubers and I was
like dude of all your businesses like
feast or whatever yeah this is like the
most underrated one because I'm like
this is genius it's selling your sawdust
your your byproduct stuff you already
built in the house you're just making it
available for others like that's a no
and you're Mr Beast if you just said hey
every YouTuber like you can use what I
use they'll all sign up right so it's
like instant customer acquisition paying
and they take like they're like dude you
don't even have a page in the
Philippines we're going to run we're
going to create it we're going to run it
for you we get half or whatever we get
30 to 50%
so it's like they don't just take like a
monthly fee they own like you know the
majority you know like a huge chunk of
that channel I'm like that's a really
good model yeah I wonder if anyone's
done like a rollup of YouTube channels
and brands or whatever like that seems
like seems like every Niche ends up
being like you get R get rolled up and
do that so I don't know I heard spotter
no I haven't notic so they're kind of
doing it what they're doing is they go
to the creators and they say we'll buy
your back catalog right so they say
we'll give you $2 million a day you can
invest that in your video now to make
better videos and they're like we can
just see with AdSense we'll make our
money back in two years and then after
that like forever we profit off your
back catalog that's like the equivalent
of like Tor s selling mes whatever
exactly so they this company's like I
don't know raised a lot of money I don't
know the key is underwriting it's like I
don't know if they correctly underwrite
these deals or not yeah but like Mr Bast
sold a bunch of his back Channel a back
catalog a bunch of other people have so
I think they've like either raised that
a billion dollar valuation or we're
close doing that for YouTube I have a
friend that I work with who uh manages
speeds I you know speed the the kid uh
he manages his IP I don't know what to
call it like uh whenever there's a video
of speed going viral on YouTube or Tik
Tok whatever they will claim it and then
they make Revenue off they they'll
they'll run ads on it and I think I
think very quickly like just speed a
learn has generated like a million
dollars so far and he's like we should
just be doing this for like not just
speed like all these different creators
you know create like a big business so
that might be also like another like
within that because the way that works
is if your video if your IP is being
played by somebody else you can claim it
and either they take it down it down or
you get all the ad Revenue yeah exactly
yeah and I think and you should just do
yeah the L like get do that so because
they found like they like dis like for
people creators like speed like a lot of
the eyeballs that that is on him is not
on his videos it's on the millions of
clips and compilations and stuff that
are that that's going unclaimed like
you're just like easy money that you
could be claiming and getting so um yeah
that's probably another thing that
people should yeah look into and dude
this is so good uh this is great these
are these are fun ideas um I'm glad we
did this man this is this is awesome and
uh yeah Sean where should they follow
you or go what could they do uh yeah you
can follow me just like Twitter uman uh
isan Hawk but the last year letters of
my name's cut off so hey JQ so and
you're you're s h an I'm i s h n h AQ
that's that's my Twitter nobody knows
what H is in America uh
H uh but yeah follow me on Twitter if
you or linked it look me up put it in
the in the description uh dude amazing
I'm proud of you um you know this has
been so amazing to I've done the
validation yeah yeah you know I I'll say
it I I am super impressed I just I'm so
glad you kind of you you've taken you
know the ball you just run with it and
you're taking just such interesting
shots on goal and like whether any of
these work or not right now is pretty
secondary like yeah by the time you're
30 your scoreboard is going to be filled
up you're going to have made all the
successes you whether it was this or
that I don't know which one yeah by the
time you're 30 you're going to have it
all done in terms of like you know the
achievement side but you're also just
going to have had so much fun right and
like you know these lessons you're
learning about like hiring these kids in
Japan because of this yeah those are the
real lessons of business and so I'm so
glad you're you're getting man this is
so cool to see thanks I appreciate it
I've got one last question for you I you
said so you I forgot like your one life
goal was like I think it was like you
want to educate was a 1% of the world or
whatever I what I said what I had said
at the time was I want to be like for 1%
of the world I want to be their favorite
teacher yeah like you know which was at
the time I think like 60 million people
or something like that I was like if if
60 million people thought like because
like for me I'm like oh like I learned
so much
from Tony Robbins or Tim Ferris or Nal
or these people like I'd love to just be
that for for people I think that's like
yeah I know what they kind of have done
for me that'd be so cool if I was that
for other people that I think that would
be like the highest calling for me yeah
yeah and do you think so is that a is
that still the case and then be like do
you still want to do that and then B uh
like what do you think will be the what
do you think will be like the Avenue
that way you achieve that like is a is
it because you're already in the ears of
you know all these people whatever the
stats are now yeah very different so
that's it but um you'll be it's St
actually that goal that goal I think
was arbitrary like who cares if it's 60
million who cares if it's 1% It was
ambitious like sine it sounded good but
I'm like I only need to say this to
myself like I don't I need to believe it
for myself what this what this actually
means and that's not something I like
needed to die to do you know like I I
didn't like feel like it was Do or Die
to do be to be able to pull that off it
was something that like sounded better
than what I really meant it was also
kind of virtue signally like you know um
I don't even know if like teacher is the
right word but I guess the thing that I
think about now is uh almost like the d
i i i stripped the ambition out of that
and just made it really simple but more
true for me which was I want to be
somebody that if I was 21 I would look
up to this person like I'd be like that
is what I want to be that guy is awesome
and that's a combination of things so
for example part of is making content
being out there otherwise I wouldn't
have even known that this guy existed
part of it is do cool [__] so that like
stuff that like I respect uh or I think
is cool in some way some of it is like
build a cool business some of it's like
uh you know this Outcast conference like
that's cool I'm like I like his
reasoning behind that I like that he
went and did it or like you know you
know just giving somebody you know a
bunch of money because you believe in
them and like my version of philanthropy
it's not like donating to to the cause
and going and sitting on the board of
some nonprofit but like if you see
somebody who's got a dream like fund it
and like make that happen so I want to
do cool [__] that like I would respect
and the last part is the way you come
across like I I know that my favorite
people were charismatic storytellers
they were funny they were likable they
didn't feel like they were bullshitting
you they had moments where they were
honest and like they could have just not
shared that or they could have said a
sanitized version but they chose to just
be real so I'm like those became my like
scoreboards is like would I at age 18 to
24 like would I have thought this guy's
the man and like I know even at that
time I like if I saw someone that was
awesome like Elon Musk oh he's amazing I
remember watching some documentary about
him on the plane before he even started
like uh Tesla I think or it was like
long time ago and I remember thinking
this guy's awesome but he had like had
four marriages at that point I was like
that's not winning to me yeah I like
that he's an outlier in this one domain
but like I didn't want to replicate
these other three so like you know to me
I'm like the thing I would have
respected is somebody who's like just
like they're really great dad like for
example one of the things I want to do
instead of instead of doing another
business or write a check is like I want
to go coach like a high school
basketball team like Mighty Ducks style
for a year or two years or something
like that yeah and I'm if I I remember
if I had if old me if young me had heard
that some guy was some rich guy was
doing that yeah I would have been like I
don't care if he's not the richest or
most successful that guy's awesome bus
and so I just kind of want to be the
person like what's that go like be who
you needed when you were younger yeah
not needed but like be who you would
have admired when you were younger right
and uh that's the goal yeah uh not the
like exact go I had before which I don't
know if it's better or worse but like
it's more true for me I I I think you'll
say some you'll like you I think you
went to LA something you met a bunch of
like rich people and at at this point
now I've met a bunch of billionaires and
other cool people and for the most part
like a lot of rich people are like
miserable and um they and like we
mentioned before about the kids that
stay in their room and build these
businesses they lack other components of
life and I see that reflected throughout
all these people that are yeah they
they've made a bunch of money or they've
done this one cool thing but they've
neglected every other part of their life
and it's like okay it's there's yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't you know trade I
wouldn't want to I wouldn't want to be
in in those shoes um it's similar to
what the I forgot who it was with some
guy talked to the insta card year and he
was like uh are you how old are you and
he was like I'm 33 and he's like I would
and this guy's worth billions of doar he
like I'll do anything to be 33 again um
and like he would trade trade all his
money so it's like I see that a lot more
now and you know I'm hopefully
maturing before I was like yeah I just
want to get all this and get the money
and stuff like that um but yeah I think
that's something cool and one thing that
one of probably the most important thing
not important but like effective things
that I learn work under you um was every
maybe it was maybe you're talking to
suly or suly taught you this was like
aggression like just being like
aggressive in like getting getting
things done and what you want like I
think most people don't don't do that
like they don't follow up or you know
they don't they don't be annoying like
they don't they don't try to be annoying
um when I when I started applying that I
was like okay things are moving way way
way faster yeah I remember probably like
because I used to kind of you were like
my dear diary it's like I come home and
I'd be like
I don't even know what time it was your
time you know I'd be like 3: a.m. yeah
be 3 a.m. and I'd be like hey I'm ready
to work and like I'd be like I met this
guy or I noticed this thing and I would
like kind of like use you as my sounding
board to like play some of these lessons
back yeah so it's cool to hear what like
stuck but yeah that that idea of like
intensity is the strategy meaning like
yeah this guy's not smarter than me he's
not yeah more knowledgeable than me
about this he's not like there's no
special Aura around this person what is
it that's made this person so successful
and what what do I what's the difference
between me and them and I just noticed I
was like oh he doesn't have these like
imaginary walls where it's like you stop
here right he just like no like okay we
want to do this like I remember one time
we wanted to do a deal the guy who we
want to invest in this company and he
was like the iy was kind of on the fence
and he was like what if we just wire him
the money and I was like $2 million and
he's like he's like yeah like well wire
him the money he's honest guy like we
met the guy he's like not like a crook
yeah um he's like let's just wire him
the money and then like I feel like
that'll tip the scale once the money's
in his bank account he's not gonna like
want to like wire it back and I was like
this guy's insane and like we had
another moment like that where we were
working on a one of the founders was
like oh I really need to raise this
round and they're telling us this
urgency I really got to do this we're
running out of money uh the the pitches
are not going well the first few pitches
didn't go well can you guys help we're
like yeah we can help we can you help
right now sounded like an emergency oh
we got a a thing like you got a thing
you just said this is like so important
okay whenever you can they get on they
get on a call with us we go through the
deck before we we said send the deck in
advance there's like 40 minutes before
the call what do most people do 40
minutes the call this we'll talk about
it in 40 minutes yeah no no no silly was
like by the time the call happened he'
already emailed back like slides 9
through 13 suck eliminate them slide
four is backwards put it in slide one
slide one needs to say this had already
given him the full first round of
feedback yeah they were like what the
hell so they were like looking at it and
we're like cool let's just make these
changes right now like no no we don't
want we want to be respectful of your
time he's like the thing that's
respectful of my time is like showing
that you're like full force going for
this not yeah that you're not going to
use my time I'm here to help but like
let's do the thing yeah you want to make
this awesome let's make it awesome so
they started working on it and they're
like okay we we know what we need to do
next because we need to go pull some
data and do whatever and um so we'll
check back in with you whenever he's
like uh you know it was like noon and
he's like cool like let's check in at 6
p.m. today and they're like two calls in
a day and even I was like two calls in a
day I've never done that with somebody
have you ever scheduled two calls in one
day with somebody like it never happens
it's not that it's so crazy it's not
like running into a burning building but
it's kind of the business equivalent of
running into it's like whoa that's
unusual that's like a highly intense way
to do this yeah you can tell they were
kind of shipped by it and then they did
it and at 6 p.m it was like still not
like exactly where we needed it to be or
we realized something and we're like
cool 9:00 a.m. tomorrow let's do it
again
by the third day we were like this deck
is in great shape but these guys were
like worn out yeah and suly was like
dude I'm just getting warmed up this is
this is like what I live for is find the
thing and laser in and to go for it and
like what who says we can't meet twice
in a day who says that they said no to
the first proposal well let's what if
you know there is some number they'll do
this app what's that number and like you
know he'll just think about it
differently yeah that stuck with me I'm
glad that kind of that idea stuck with
you I say it out loud so that somebody
out there listening will be realize like
yo my intensity knob is stuck at six
yeah like 10 isn't more hours it's just
like more focus and it's more intensity
at the main issue and not self-limiting
and some by by fake imaginary walls that
don't exist yeah yeah you got to bring
the NG uh ni SP boy stuff that's there
we go all right that's it that's the
[Music]
pod